[Music]
it's like he gets it backwards so there
is a federal response to covet it's just
not what he's doing so what he's doing
is imposing unconstitutional mandates
you know there's these ocean mandates
that would require businesses to fire
workers who aren't vaccinated that's the
opposite of what he should be doing
well there you have it congressman
crenshaw says biden's vax mandate for
business is unconstitutional and a slew
of republicans agree 47 senators and
nearly 140 house members have asked and
banded together on the issue they are
asking the supreme court to block that
mandate and remember there is a 6-3
conservative majority among the justices
the high court has upheld many state and
local vaccine mandates but that may not
save the presidents guy lewis is a
former u.s attorney guy thank you for
coming on we very much appreciate it so
the big argument here seems to be that
these mandates are not really within the
purview of the occupational safety and
health administration is that a sound
argument in your assessment
trace i i think you've hit the nail
right on the head i mean let's go back
the osha the the act they're traveling
under uh was established in 1970
frankly as a result of there being
asbestos and other hazardous materials
in the workplace and so the question
becomes
is is really it's a constitutional
struggle of epic proportions how much
how much power does the federal
government and in this case joe biden in
the white house have over your daily
lives can he kick you out of the
military can he get the hospitals to
fire you can he does he have all this
power over the individual and the
decision-making as opposed to the state
or or the local government and and some
would say you know is this really about
federal power the president's power or
is this a fight about the flexibility
that federal agencies have
during times of emergencies like the
pandemic
so great question but think about what's
not occurred here i mean this is a law
that he's actually following and uh as
an executive that he's affecting as a
result of being president this is
basically his own mandate
out of the white house we've not had
hearings we've not had votes there's
there's been no legal process
and so i i think in terms of the court
the supreme court setting this on an
emergency basis oral argument january
7th i think it tells us a lot about how
seriously the supreme court takes this
um this mandate
yeah you mentioned you talked about
military earlier i want to put this up
on the screen because now we have
confirmed that 206 marines have been
fired marines have been fired for
refusing
the vaccination where do you think this
goes guy
boy you make a great point and the irony
don't the irony is almost incredible to
me that you're firing hospital workers
you're fired and then we've got people
lined up uh here in miami-dade county uh
literally waiting five six seven hours
just for a coveted test because there's
not enough equipment there's not enough
people
i think this is going to the supreme
court and i frankly think they're going
to step in and decide it's too much
power for the federal government make a
good point man with these people we come
they come
back from from overseas missions and we
thank them for their service and now we
are firing them because they won't get a
shot guy lewis great to see you as
always happy new year sir hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now